Okay, so we've now seen an abstract example of
decision trees. So let's make certain that we understand
it with a concrete example. So, to your right
is a specific decision tree that looks at some of
the features that we talked about. Whether you are
occupied or not, whether the restaurant is occupied or not
what type of restaurant it is. Your choices are
pizza, Thai, or other. And whether the people inside look
happy or not. The possible outputs are again binary
either you don't go or you do go, into
the restaurant. On your left is a table which
has six of the features that we've talked about. Whether
the restaurant is occupied or not, the type of
restaurant, whether it's raining outside or not, whether your hungry
or not. Whether you're on a hot and whether
the people inside look happy, and some values for each
of those. And what we would like for you to do is to
tell us what the output of this decision tree would be in each case.
>> Alright, so the decision tree here is a, it's
a classifier, but we had another name. Oh, it's a concept.
>> Yes.
>> Alright, and each row of this is a different time that
we're stopping at a restaurant, and the, the little values there summarize what
is true about this particular situation. And, and you're saying we need
to then trace through this decision tree and figure out what class is,
okay yeah, that's what you said. Okay, I'm
ready. Alright, perfect. Okay, that's the quiz, go.